what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef also guys make
sure you like the video on your way and
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so if you like the streams and you want
to support them make sure you like the
video a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is that we have
two clips channels the first is just
pearly clips and the second is Pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
we have two different editors on those
accounts so you just get different types
of Clips the second is that we have four
membership tiers if you want to be a
part of the live chat today make sure
you sign up for the first tier it is the
price of a cup of coffee a month and it
helps us get new updates in the studio
like blessings monopod right blessing
yeah he wants a new monopod so go go
sign up for that tier the second tier um
you get to see our Discord and our
behind the scenes Vlogs I think we're
gonna film I I feel bad I've been
promising this for a minute but we are
going to film a behind the scenes Vlog
of the penthouse what do you think
blessing this week
Saturday we're gonna film it so if you
want to see that sign up for the second
tier the third tier you get to connect
with me on social media that means
having access to my inbox and the fourth
tier you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month I really recommend this
tier because I haven't helped people
grow on YouTube and I also you know some
people just have questions about the
show big fans I don't know either way I
really recommend the fourth tier if
you're in social media and you want to
grow on YouTube um the link to that
should be in the chat
um it should be the pinned comment okay
also guys um they took away my Instagram
I know
I was shocked too I couldn't believe it
so uh my new Instagram is just pearly
things one I'm trying to get to 5 or 10K
on there so make sure you go follow that
um also this is the first stream that we
are at 700 000 subscribers
which again which again is so mad
because I started the show in like March
so 700 100K and seven eight months like
that's crazy I I'm in shock every single
day that I get to do this
um so thank you guys but subscribe so we
can hit 750.
um also guys if you want to come on the
show DM the pregame show podcast that
should be in the description but guys
you have to be in London um if you want
to come to London and come on the show
that's fine but you can't uh We're not
gonna like Zoom call people in you have
to be in London if you want to come on
the show
um also go subscribe to um the wife
School channel that should be in the
chat as well
um that is we want to do the first
episode when we hit a thousand
subscribers because that helps us get
monetized on that channel
and it's actually interesting I went
through a whole style transformation
where they were like going through my
closet and stuff so if you want to go
see that go sign up for wife school and
um all super chats today are going
towards blessings monopod so if you guys
want to Super Chat um so blessing can
get a monopod okay so um today we have a
lovely panel so why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself so starting here and then go
around
uh so my name is handles handles tdmb is
what I go by
um
32
and my status is single
contract oh and fun fact
a fun fact about me
um
I'm actually pretty pretty good at music
um and I do quite well in music to be
fair so you know music is my life so
that's a fun fact about me is music
that's the fun side to me
um I'm Courtney I'm nearly 28 and my
Estates is currently single and the fun
fact about me is that I've got a black
belt in karate
all right
um I'm Octavia I'm 39.
um my relationship status is in a
relationship and
fun fact about me would be that I have a
twin brother
oh it's kind of people I go by big gang
um and as you know I've been connecting
bids since 2019.
did you say your relationship status ah
taken is that your fun fact the
connecting beards yeah okay okay God
yo my name is Saya AKA sire the God and
one half of the judging it podcast and
artist and fun fact is it's my birthday
on Monday so give me some love
what no love
Monday
okay so all right cool and I'm 34. yeah
my name is Big scoop
um I'm 34 and a fun fact about me
is that I can do the shuffle like James
Brown
and my relationship status is single
okay so um what did I title oh they
titled this
should today's topic is should modern
women compete for a man
now I'll tell you why I was inspired by
this this week we had a girl come on the
show Tuesday
now this girl was a proud side chick
yeah yeah she she came home she she had
a man but she she like knew he had a
girlfriend and like she's she's side
chick and it really had me beg the
question
actually I'm going to get to that later
I'm going to get to that later so to
start have you guys ever had a side
chick or been a side chick
yeah I've had a side chick okay so you
have yeah off the side chick you've been
a side check yeah I have
well I did not plan this at all
uh no no official side chick
with multiple things at the same time
okay unofficial
yeah no I've never had a side chick per
se by juggling yeah right not side chick
I would say yes so when you guys hear
side chick is when I think of side chick
I think there's like a main chick and
then like they're like you know exactly
because I don't I don't think it's a
side chick if you you juggle multiple
wouldn't that I actually have a question
do you guys think what's the difference
between a side chick a mistress and a
sneaky link
uh Society Mitch is in a sneaky link he
said what's the difference yeah
side chick is when you've got a girl and
and then you've got another girl as well
on the side that doesn't necessarily
know about
the yeah they don't know about each
other okay okay Mysteries more for
married people if you're married and
you've got a side chick it's a Mysteries
okay kind of upgraded side chick
because when I think of a sneaky link
like that is they're not in a
relationship it's just like yeah that's
just somebody you sneak around with late
nights past 11 o'clock
okay so question for the guys that said
yes to having a side chick
what
made you want to get a side chick
um
your girlfriend not doing something
that's usually the reason for a side
chick because you know like if he if you
get into a relationship with a girl she
kind of gives you like a terms and
conditions list like without even saying
it really so you know what you can kind
of get from your main goal because you
know in
return
you you know you're taking her out in
public whereas your side chick she
doesn't really care about being out in
public and she might do the things that
your main girl might not that's kind of
how she might have crept into you know
being my side chick by doing the stuff
my main thing wasn't doing could I have
an example of something
um
learning when
to be quiet
okay like just accepting something and
just being like all right cool so you're
just leaving it so your main girl was
always arguing with you yeah and so like
that just got tiring so then you were
like I need to find someone who gives me
peace some peace and quiet and so why
did you not promote the side chick to
Maine
because
being a side chick
you can't really okay promote once you
come in as a side chick you're never
coming out nah you're never coming out
you're never coming out the site you're
staying in the friend zone absolutely
men we have that I'll be putting them in
the side chick friend zone too once
you're in there you come in that gate
you leave in that gate you know what I
mean so so what do you guys think can
um a side chick be promoted to Main
Chick
go ahead
nah simple as simple as that I don't
think so no side chicks if if it's a
girl that is um that you don't uh
necessarily respect enough to be your
actual wife then she's not that's not
what she's for she's for she serves a
purpose they're usually not as good
looking as well it's like usually a
Walmart version or your girlfriend yeah
yeah the b-tech version
if your main girl leaves you and you
Splunk with your misses
it would decide the side chick's gonna
become your main goal anyway
yeah that person that that turns into a
sneaky link
and then you go and watch someone else
you know I mean
um what about you guys so being on the
other end of that what was it like being
a side chick horrendous horrendous I
think being a side chick you still class
yourself as even though you know your
side chick you still like to think that
you're their main girl or you're the
person bringing all the fun to them so
it still feels like you're their main
girl but then you know it's never going
anywhere you're never stepping out of
that zone because you let yourself come
into that zone that's always the problem
why'd you stay
uh because it's fun yeah and and I think
a part of you still hopes that you might
they might promote you to their main
chick but that never happens ever so
absolutely
um for me it was it was fine because I
knew what I was getting into
um I knew I was the side chick and I
didn't want nothing else and it was what
it was so for me it was fine but I think
if you understand going in that you're
not going to be upgraded and you're not
emotionally attached to the person that
try not to get emoji attached then you
can do it successfully yeah
okay blessing I know you're fixing the
camera but I need you to pull the yeah
yeah
so we have a video we're gonna react to
and I just want to see everyone's
it's called
um
side chicks have high self-esteem yeah
what up YouTube
it's a big homie AP
and this is for all the women
that think that side chicks have low
self-esteem
okay
I've heard that [ __ ] so many times in my
life
or when I talk about the women I've
dated and [ __ ] and women say I mean
that's that type of woman I mean you you
know those women have low self-esteem to
[ __ ] with somebody like you and this
that and the other
let me explain this [ __ ] so y'all can
finally get an understanding and and
understand that these women have the
highest self-esteem
okay
first of all
foreign
that is a quote-unquote side chick
she doesn't go into this situation like
oh man I can't get a man for myself so
uh I might as well latch on to somebody
else [ __ ] or uh you know
you know I don't deserve a man of my own
so I might as well deal with whoever
will [ __ ] with me that's not their
[ __ ] attitude all right their
attitude is like well [ __ ] if he talking
to me
if you've given me time and attention if
he willing to take me out if you're
willing to spend money on me
somebody ain't handling their [ __ ]
business at home you know what I'm
saying and that might not be true but
this is how they think this is how a
woman feels she might feel like or you
know what
[ __ ] he might got a chick now
he might like his check
but when he gets some of this [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying or where or
when when he get when he get a dose of
me
man he ain't going home you know what
I'm saying he gonna he gonna call her up
like on Harlem Nights likes like yeah
baby I ain't coming home you know what
I'm saying so
that's the that's the mentality of a
side chick not no uh oh I I I can't get
a man of my own or you know all that
kind of dumb [ __ ] these women go in like
well [ __ ] he can't he can't be too happy
if he barking up my tree you know he
calling my phone all the [ __ ] time he
seemed to be always available for me
you know what I'm saying they damn never
start feeling like man that can't be
serious what they got
you know if he if he coming at me this
hard they can't be straight
but never are these women
are down and out feeling like they can't
get another man or get a man or they own
most of them have options
most of these women could
not every man is qualified
okay and not only are
do a side chicks have high self-esteem
they're real good at math
let me explain why side chicks are so
good at math okay
I should have did the real numbers but
let's let's just assume there's
so many million men in the United States
and so many million women
now out of those millions of men
subtract the man that are married
okay
now subtract the men that are gay
now subtract the men that are under five
foot
five
then subtract the man
that are attractive
or or unattractive subtract the ugly
[ __ ]
then subtract the people with
disabilities the males that you know the
disabled men
then subtract the men that are you know
either crazy or or or you know mentally
disabled
now subtract all the men or males that
are under
20 under under 18 I should say
now subtract the man that got jobs or or
you know the men that don't got jobs
subtract them man
who
[Laughter]
subtract the man who know how to talk to
women okay
then subtract the man who uh
who have an education a high school
diploma or a job you know what I'm
saying the point I'm trying to make
is by the time you subtract all of these
undesirable men
y'all have a extremely small pool and
then I ain't get into the [ __ ] in jail
okay so y'all have the smallest pool of
men to choose from
just off top man that you would actually
want and be happy with are very very
limited in the United States really all
over the world but we're talking about
here okay
so now you're saying this woman that's a
side chick
she got low self-esteem
I think she just good at math I think
she realized there is a limited amount
of quality men
and if she's gonna want one for herself
she's gonna have to get out there and
compete for him
and the women that say stupid [ __ ] like
see that's why I don't need no man I'm
just I'm just be by myself then to do
all that you know what that tell me you
got low self-esteem
because if you have high self-esteem
you're afraid to get out here and
compete
you wouldn't be afraid to get get your
hair done and your nails done and put on
some clothes and go out here and take
you a [ __ ] you know what I'm saying you
got low self-esteem
that's what the [ __ ] I heard when you
said I just be by myself then because
you don't think you got what it takes to
get a man you don't think you got what
it takes to to out-compete another woman
you know what I'm saying hold up y'all
somebody wasting my goddamn time blowing
my phone up unknown ass number two Okay
so
the reason
the reason I thought of this the other
day camp is this girl's on my show and
she's talking about she was a side chick
she's really cool shout out you know if
she's watching tonight but I was just
thinking
like you're already on the show saying
proclaiming your side chick you might as
well compete and try to win because she
was saying she wouldn't date him after
why are you a side chick if you want you
know what I'm saying like I'm not saying
to do that I'm just if you're gonna do
it anyways my point is do you think that
women should compete for a man
absolutely
definitely with a prize
we're the ones who control marriage we
control Legacy
like
we do all the hard work essentially in
terms of infrastructure so why wouldn't
you compete for us it doesn't make any
sense even if he's got a girl even if
yeah of course that's that's the real
company like you when you think about it
to like a point where you know
our communities were married a lot more
like you know I'm saying like the
marriage rate was a lot higher
the competition was even more steep
that's why they made songs like Rolling
Stones and this is what what he's
basically saying which is true which is
like modern women don't really have game
this is why they're struggling to keep a
man because getting a man's attention is
easy
a fast car could drive past and men
would be like oh did you see that it's
getting our attention is easy but
keeping our attention is where I feel
you know people have lost that respect
and that's why we don't get treated like
a prize because you feel like we're not
the prize until
you become a side chick and you realize
there is actually a prize
what about you guys
would you compete for a man no no
absolutely no no why
why should I why shouldn't he compete
for me why am I competing against
another girl if I'm not good enough then
he doesn't deserve me if if he's
comparing me against against another
woman saying oh you know her her
qualities and and traits might be better
why
like if I'm not good enough then you
don't deserve me you don't think that
you compare him to other men yeah but
then I'm not asking him to compete as in
if if the man is in the lineup he would
be the that man that I would then go and
see like women don't have
sidemen or whatever so
that's not true we would definitely have
what did you just say we definitely do
um
you have go around the corner guys as
well
women don't have sidemen Jesus so how
does a five foot do compete with a six
foot dude well they don't there's no
competition
as in if I was looking I wouldn't look
at the five foot two I would look at the
six foot what makes you think that the
six foot dude is looking at you
well you just know how
but you don't you don't think okay so so
if it's a guy that you're attracted to
like how you don't meet guys that you're
really into often right yes like it's
probably rare for you you find a guy
that you're really really into yeah
right yeah so you find him and if you're
really really into him other women are
probably really really into him right
that's how it goes right yeah so it's
like if he's talking to five girls and
they're they're let's say within a point
pretty right they're all up like within
a point
how does he pick
s the best one okay so how would you
show if you're applying for a job
like wouldn't you compete for that job
and get the right skills for it I would
I think compete is the wrong word though
relationships are not a job yeah it's
not your same as do you think do you
think men are competing
for the women that we want no no way no
you're not we don't compete from the
what you've said you think that women
just come to you and you've got them
for me but I'm an exception to the rule
okay because I already know that there's
like like the dude just said there's a
small percentage of men that are
smashing everything
[Music]
um
I know the 90 of dudes that not that are
at work every day that are completely
invisible
so when I hear people say certain things
I'm like
you've never heard of a nerd having more
than one baby mother
it's the dude that's in jail serving 20
years that's got five baby mums why
because women like the same dude so that
same six foot guy that's in the room
that you're saying that you wouldn't
compete for maybe you might not compete
with your friends but if it's random
girls in there you're gonna compete and
you're gonna do what women do which is
try and be in his line of sight you know
how to compete
I think compete is the wrong word though
you would you would just be yourself
like and and you know what you bring to
the table like I know that when I meet a
guy I know exactly what I'm bringing to
the table do you not think that I
eyelashes eyebrows and Antarctic tan and
hair colors and hair lamps and all these
things that you're not think on your net
all of these things are competing these
are these are definitely competing no
way so why do girls spend money on their
lips if they're not competing what's
what's what's it for yourself because
it's for a while fashion good yeah I
feel better feel better than dick
foreign
no all right so it's for us you don't
try to look good for men
you don't try to like because if I if
I'm going out somewhere and I know
there's going to be attractive guys
there I'm going to try to look better
but I guess that's the same whether I'm
single or in a relationship so if I'm in
a relationship I'll still dress up and
do my hair and that's because I want to
be put together it's not for guys to
move to me I agree I don't agree with
that because as soon as you get in a
relationship with a girl it goes from
supermodel to
you've never tried to dress up for a
date like you're going on a date with
guy and you want to impress him you want
to look good of course I just dressed
but I dress how I would dress I don't
think extra outside of how I would think
like girls anywhere yeah this is why the
same way I get up in the morning and I
want to be presentable for work it's not
I'm not trying to attract guys when I go
to work do you know what are you
changing your appearance for why why tan
to freeze four different Shades Darker
for what are you trying to write that
individual thing isn't it no but I'm
just asking what is so if it's not a
competition why are we trying to get up
in a ladder or something I'm just asking
a general question I think I think
compete is actually the right word
because you in order to get anywhere in
life you need to you need to go like go
up against somebody to get what you want
so if it's something that you actually
want why would you not
um
there's there's loads of things in your
in your mind there's loads of things
that you do
to go and go for what you want so
whether that is from a woman's
perspective whether that is putting on
uh the right even perfume or the right
lipstick or the right because you know
that right listen I'm gonna do my best
because this guy right here I want this
guy do you know what I mean so that is a
it's a competition because you're trying
to beat all the other girls out there
because there's going to be loads that
you're competing with the guys with the
um with the girls that are around the
guy that you want I mean I just think
like pretty is common and so I feel like
you have to have something that makes
yourself stand out to a guy it's like
fishing yeah and so it's like if if I if
I if I'm seeing a guy and I find out his
favorite meal I'm gonna learn how to
cook it because I I want him to talk to
me and give me attention rather than the
other girls that is competing yes
you don't do that that's not gay because
this is what I was saying earlier modern
women don't have a game why wouldn't you
do that like if you like something you
meet someone what I'm saying is if I
with someone if I if I'm cooking for
someone I'm already with them I'm not
competing with other girls that they're
talking to uh you see but but that's
where you go wrong
because I've had relationships so I
don't have to compete for relationships
someone if a guy comes to me and wants
to be with me then we're together I
think I think I think I've not had
experiences where I have to go in out
and I'm seeing someone and I'm like he's
good looking and there's loads of girls
that like him so I need to do extra
things to get him yes I don't do that
okay maybe maybe not you but I think
that that is exactly where a lot of
women go wrong because absolutely
because they don't even when they jump
into a relationship they they stop
competing
normally if if it's a if it's a guy if
if they jump into a relationship
um then they're gonna they're gonna try
and
um
how they compete for you is to make
themselves better
follow their purpose you know
uh build up their status build up their
money do you know I mean that's how they
compete for for you and maybe others
whatever but if if a woman's not gonna
do not not they don't need to do the
same but if they're not gonna try and
compete even when in a relationship and
that's what that's yeah that's where it
starts compete with who everybody else
everyone else that's around that's
around when you guys were when you guys
but with the word compete
I don't do things for my partner yeah or
I I didn't say that I'm just not company
I'm not in my head going I need to cook
him dinner because someone else will I
need to dress nice because someone else
is how can I ask you a question
it's not about someone else it's just
like young people you don't you don't
wait wait you don't want a guy that's
worth competing for that's why like I
don't want a guy that no one else wants
like I'm eating there has to be other
people involved but everyone every time
you walk outside there is at your at
your man's job there's gonna be four or
five girls that are like they know full
well he's in a relationship but they
will take him and I'm aware of that
they'll take it that doesn't bother me
it's more nuanced than that though like
you're competing in a sense where you
look after him and you make sure he's
good but if you started to neglect him
and you didn't do all the things that
you do then he might start looking
elsewhere yeah
I think I think the work compete is
triggering you too much to actually like
understand
yeah when a man and woman get in a
relationship and everyone's talking
about what the woman should do to keep
the man but what is them what is the man
gonna do it goes two three do you guys
usually pay for dates
uh equal split on the first day I would
say the man should pay but after that we
can go halves or split the bill I'm I'm
happy to do that do you expect a man if
you were attacked and you were with him
do you expect him to protect you
or would you just say oh you deal with
this on your own you got it all right
she got a black belt
[Music]
he's gonna be like you've got this you
got this yeah if you get some after that
yeah how would you respond would you
want to stay with him
no no right why not
well because because men provide
protection that's why that's that's
right protection provision and
profession but he also needs to maintain
lots of things as well as a woman does
when they get into relationships no
women don't have to do nothing when they
get in a relationship that's why you get
into relationships
what do you actually have to physically
do other than keep my knees satisfied in
a relationship let's cut away you what
you're doing actually in your own life
so let's draw two circles and the two
circles that interact that is where
relationships supposed to live that's
how you last in one the other the
outsides of the circle are supposed to
be in your own lives those little
sections there what are you supposed to
what are you doing
in my own Circle no no not in your own
Circle in the middle so in the circle
that crosses with the person that you
remember relationship so you'll be
cooking him dinner
um I don't know doing his washing
deciding dates and arranging things and
I don't know a lot and would you want to
pay for anything
you're expecting that you don't pay for
nothing no no the stuff that you pay for
should be beat buying me gifts and
buying a family gifts that's the stuff
that you should be paying for right
it's what you'd want your money to be
spent on
I think that a man and woman can go
equal as in if we're going on a date or
or we're going out to a restaurant for
dinner it can be split in half it can be
I can I'm not expecting you to to pay
therefore I think that I'm still doing
my stuff you can do your stuff it's just
not about protection it's about lots of
things yeah but
we're not saying what you can do I could
put on a jump a parachute and jump off
this this Penthouse right now I could do
that but that wouldn't make any sense
what would make sense is me getting an
elevator what makes sense is the man
paying for it because you are in a
relationship that's why you're the first
thing you said was cooking food your
innate brain was to go straight to the
kitchen and if I was to say to you go
straight to the kitchen you might kick
me because you're a black belt if I was
to say it but your DNA was like food
provision home because that is
that is the natural order of things like
so what man or woman's supposed to do
will protect it's like I said you don't
you don't see nobody fighting for women
to go and fight in Ukraine when they
sent them all here
it's the men over there fighting where
where is the people protesting for the
women to stay in the Army and fight the
Russian men
it's quiet women only want equality
when it comes they don't want equality
when it comes to relationships they want
to Quality everywhere else but in terms
of relationships we want to keep it
traditional so you have to kind of pick
a side I still think that men and women
both have to come
maintain the relationship together a man
still got to put in just as much as
effort as a woman I I agree I agree with
that I think I think I think I said that
earlier like a man has to compete me we
compete daily I think we day in day out
we can please show me the number one of
the number one causes of divorce is
financial women tend to leave um 70 to
80 of the time ninety percent of she's
college educated so I might have to
compete every day in the workforce to to
keep us one of the number one indicators
that a man is going to get divorced is
that his woman out earns him
so it's like if they don't make enough
money we leave statistically
they weren't on someone on their level
or above yeah so but anyways I have a I
have an unpopular opinion and I've been
thinking about this I've been thinking
about this for like four days now so
it's a lot of fun four days yeah because
this girl came on my show on Tuesday and
she was talking about she was a side
chick and everyone in the comments and
even Sarah was saying oh she has low
self-esteem and I was kind of thinking
I respect side chicks I really do I
really I love out of respect for set and
let me tell you why okay one out of four
marriages are sexless meaning that the
man hasn't gotten sex I mean you could
argue the woman too but usually it's the
woman withholding the sex
um I think it's in three months
something like that and that's
classified as sexless
if you're not sleeping with your husband
[Music]
um
and a girl says I'm gonna she sees an
opportunity she's like oh this guy could
protect provide um I I think he would be
a good boyfriend or a good husband can
you really be mad if he gets a side
chick
if if you're not sleeping with him
anyway
nope sorry I know you would say no you
agree with me okay I agree yeah yeah I
wouldn't be mad because I don't like go
for it honey yeah like if she saw an
opportunity I'm like God what do you
think
uh I don't know about that I think that
he should be loyal because they're mate
so what
it's it's not all about it's not all
about that is it it's it's about lots of
other things that if if a woman's not
sleeping with you there's obviously a
reason for it so you've got to get to
that reason before
now what if it's a stupid reason
what's the stupid reason I'm insecure
with my body yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
I feel like it I don't
um I don't know I think that is a stupid
reason and and to not sleep with someone
because of that is is mad but I don't
think it's okay for a man to go and get
us a side chick just because of that
what where's the Loyalty at like when we
get in a relationship I'm getting in a
relationship with you thinking that
you're gonna respect me be loyal yeah
but he he went in the relationship
thinking he was going to get sex
would you buy a car without an engine no
so like what if you what if you bought a
car and then boom three months in the
engine's gone
he's like he's like [ __ ] I gotta get to
work why am I call moving I've got a
steering wheel kids
I've got all everything why are my car
moving because women seem to forget that
the engine in the relationship is that
coochie that's what we got to work for
that's what we do 20 hours 40 hours 60
hours for so we can come home hear
nothing and be blessed with God's
greatest creation
I get that I just still don't think it's
all right for a man to just go elsewhere
I used to I used to kind of think like
that then I changed my mind yeah it was
four days
like four days it's not a long time when
you think about it because honestly
you're gonna be a side chick compete are
you already in that role comfy try to
win now but sometimes
what I watched that episode was that she
said she wouldn't trust him because then
she thinks that he would then just well
I'm just saying she was already in love
like she's basically in love with him so
I'm like you're already in that
situation besides you just like being
side chicks though because there's
benefits to being a side chick are you
saying that a side chick should be
content with being the side chick that
whoever you're speaking about you saying
she should just be content no I said she
should compete she should try to win
right I'm not saying it's good odds I'm
not even saying I'd recommend it I'm
just saying like I I can't fault someone
if you're if you're and I'm not saying I
don't know the his girlfriend's
situation whatever but it's like I know
the numbers behind it and I know there's
a lot of men in marriages that they
can't get out because she can leave and
take half your [ __ ] and she so and she
can take your kids with you and then on
top of that like he's basically chained
in because one out of four marriages are
sexless so she cannot sleep with him and
then he doesn't want to get a divorce
because she's going to take half the
[ __ ] so it's like if he's there's a lot
of men that are in those situations and
it's and it's like if one out of four
men are in those situations and another
girl comes in and sees this like I just
I gotta respect the game that's all I
say the game
it's the game you shouldn't have
neglected your like because girls will
always talk about you know he cheated he
cheated and like go on social media and
cry about it but we never talk about why
did he cheat what were you not doing
that he cheated
and the thing is women do this all the
time since I can probably remember
because we know it's it's a sacrifice as
men we know if we want to have a great
career we've got to sacrifice
relationships and family if we don't
want to be rich and famous then we'll
have a great family and we'll have you
know we'll have great relationships so
we've all heard the story of the husband
who works too much the husband who's
always on a business trip yeah we what's
wife doing with her PT with her personal
trainer with Jose that does yoga what's
going on Tom Brady and Giselle come on
this is and this is and women have been
doing this for time they make movies
about it it's called Sex in the City
yeah
it's a blockbuster who was buying those
tickets
he was going to watch that and entertain
that that's a lot did you go to the
cinema to watch Sex in the City no did
you no but if you watched it though no
are you sure promise all right
you know what I'm saying so you agree
though and you don't you you think he
should be loyal even if she's not
sleeping with him yeah if if they're
ready for a divorce and and you know
that's where the relationship's going or
whatever and he's already fallen in love
with someone else fun but he he
shouldn't just go and get a side chick
because she's not sleeping with him I
just feel like what what happened to
loyalty for for how long do you think so
um as in how long could she not sleep
with him before
if a man doesn't want to lose his assets
because especially in the UK I've heard
divorce laws are really bad here like a
guy can lose up to 70 of his assets in a
divorce and if he says you know what I
want to keep my stuff and she's not
having sex with him how long should he
deal with that until he cheats or should
he just be in that forever
um I don't think he should be in that
forever obviously that's not fair at all
but the if if she's not sleeping with
him because they aren't actually or or
they're heading for a divorce anyway
that I think that's that's different he
shouldn't just go out and find it
because she's not slept with him for a
couple months I don't think that's all
right no way so don't you think that a
man's gonna think right if my woman is
not sleeping with me who is she sleeping
with
because I mean
if you if he flipped it
and I wasn't sleeping with you
for three months I would be thinking I
would be thinking I'd be thinking what I
haven't stuck it on you for free I ain't
walked past you in the kitchen and smack
your ass nothing for three months you're
gonna be in my you're gonna be on my
phone you're gonna be in my phone you're
gonna be in my phone figuring out who's
riding it because it ain't been me
no I've I think he's like
I agree I think that I would think you
know if if I if he didn't sleep with me
or whatever I'd be thinking who is he
sleeping with but it I don't think that
that makes it all right it's still not
all right how how does that make it okay
look I'm not even saying it's okay I
just respect it that I heard blessing
can I tell the Zimbabwe story you told
me yeah yeah blessing was telling me the
other day that what happens is so I
don't know if you guys a lot of men are
leaving
um the West to go find wives so they're
going to like places where women are a
little bit more traditional in the East
and and blessing toll makes he's from
Zimbabwe that um fam like um the
Zimbabwe men here will be dating a girl
um or married to a girl and then
basically they'll go do business in
Zimbabwe for two months and those girls
there are traditional and they want they
look at that man like that is their meal
ticket so they treat him like an
absolute King and just like worship the
ground he walks on and like they ruin
like families and while I don't
recommend that it's like if if she's
doing something you're not
I just respect the game
this game
modern women have lost the game yeah
they don't have no more games and just
sit there look pretty you think if I put
a BBL on I'll get my life changed no
you're nothing like great grandma you're
nothing like Grandma that was cooking
pot pies making meals for the boys
getting the dominoes ready like playing
the music there's so much little things
that modern women are losing out on with
an experience by just feeling entitled
for some reason yeah well and it's just
like because it's just common like a lot
of guys will say like one in four
marriages are sexless on top of that
like girls gain a bunch of weight after
they get married and then you know they
stop sleeping them with them after they
have the kids they don't cook they don't
clean they don't do the things that like
men want and so it's like if a girl
comes in if you're not doing your job as
a wife like how can then leave the girl
don't don't have a side chick I I would
agree with you I know what you're saying
if the government didn't trap them I
would agree with you if they weren't I
mean imagine been working for 20 years
and she could take 70 percent of that
and the kids I think what it is a lot of
the time when when
um
when it is like a secless marriage
situation yeah a lot of the time that is
kind of done on purpose because I think
a lot of
um I think a lot of women know that that
is leverage so they're not necessarily
some sometimes it is done on purpose I'm
not gonna do this okay because you're
not doing this so I know that this is
something that I I know you want I'm not
going to give it to you but when it's
done with that kind of mindset it's not
worth it it's not it's definitely not
worth it on for for the for the woman
because it's gonna again it's gonna make
he's not gonna make that guy do anything
go oh it shouldn't really because again
that guy shouldn't be this should be
sort of bending over for for the punan
well yeah I feel sorry for them guys to
be honest yeah I'm working paying the
bills and not getting nothing at home
dry Sahara Desert blue balls Peak it's
Peak
it's pretty sad don't you think about it
though they must feel like trapped
it's like it's like it's not very good
advert for marriages to be honest it was
it's like you you would feel like you've
been tricked because a beginning of the
relationship you were like humping like
rabbits yeah and then halfway through uh
you know suddenly
where's this person gone do you know
what I mean that was that was jumping on
me all them years ago like well I'm
going for it yeah do you know what it is
here women have like they're like innate
players so it's like once they've
completed their mission of I've got your
time and attention they go dead oh
actually I have a video that kind of
blessing do video number two so have you
guys seen Kevin Samuels before rip the
Godfather man how you mean man
so um this was he had a caller that
called into his show
foreign
papers and you divorce inside in 90 days
would you keep those 60 pounds on
no why
because I gotta get back out there I
guess oh damn so basically you're
telling your husband is because the the
the the the the prize for you staying in
this marriage is me having this
additional 60 pounds but if you were to
leave me I'd lose it
I am working to get it off though I am
working to get it off
I just I mean I just gave it to you
plain and simple I'll let you resolve
that
so I have a question for the man
how much weight is too much weight to
gain in a relationship that is
disrespectful to you
today do they get any wiggle room per
kid yeah let me know all right
yeah you're going for it today anyway
um
20 pounds plus you putting on 20 pounds
plus wait what's that in kg I can't even
think in pounds we'll see what's that in
kg makes no sense I don't know that's
about I think Empower I don't know one
and a half Stars kg that would be like
three stones if you put on three stone
that's a bit mad yeah three stone is mad
yeah between three and five like
anything plus even if you're
circumstantial like the hell for yeah
like kids Etc kids if it's to do if
you're doing kids that is probably the
one thing that you could uh give the
benefit of the day that's a that's a
stone and a half bro because you know
that's gonna happen and then but you but
you would eventually expect that you
know you're gonna put in some some work
to get that to get that back why because
you see loads of men age 40 plus with
things like beer bellies what are they
doing right I was gonna ask you I
I get that but men but but women women
like men for different things they don't
like that
men are more visuals so that's why that
women will date anybody like women will
get with any man do you know what I mean
they're not looking at you for like some
some women like the beer the beer bit
that's that's what they like they like
they like bellies they like you know man
boobs and all that kind of thing that's
what they like
but do you think it's more to do with
not so much they're putting on weight
but if you feel like they're not taking
care of themselves anymore
and they don't dress well but that's it
it's the Internet it's the inactivity
for me okay would you pick would you
pick a girl that gained no weight but
dressed like a bum or a girl that like
dressed really well became 50 pounds
dressed like a bum yeah yeah that one
that's what I wrote like Wade is the
ultimate form of like letting go to my
to man right would you say yeah from
since you've been in school we all know
it the girl that was fine and slim and
active in school you walk past when you
29 30 you don't even recognize that oh
it's you yeah how many times I've done
that from school like oh how are you
doing how's it how's the kids and you
don't want to say it well but you know
what's going on well and the one thing
is if you look at women like back from
like the 20s and 30s and you look at old
pictures they all bounce back after
pregnancy even in like the 1800s oh my
God those those women had like three
times the amount of kids we did and they
all they all look good
yup
main thing it just shows like you just
don't care in it like if if you put an
effort to get back in shape or stay in
shape when you get into relationship it
just shows that you're putting in effort
in your care so as a collector of
collective you guys said 20 pounds you
said 20. you'll give your girl 20.
that's something excuse me some kids
yeah like yeah yeah okay okay no he's
like ah maybe not 20. you're not not 20.
once it starts going over 20 I'm gonna
be like maybe come on it depends on how
you look because some some women put on
weight but but okay it is for it's
falling in the right places but if it
starts becoming you you're you're not in
control of it if I can see that you're
not in control of your weight gain
that's a problem because if it's
purposeful because if it's purposeful
weight gain there's there's a certain
lifestyle that goes with that you know I
mean it could you can wait you can put
on weight like you know what I mean in
certain areas that will that will shape
your body and make it look like boom but
if if if you're not if you're not in
control if I can see that that weight
gain although it looks good you you
didn't know why you gained that weight
how you gained that weight then I would
be like then that would be a red flag
for me
so would you give her 30 pounds how much
roughly you could give me a ride I need
it in kg or I would say I would say 10 I
would say 10
to 15 kg is nuts I'll do 15 kgs I'm sure
that's about 20 pounds
no 33 pounds 33 pounds yeah 10 to 15 kgs
man that's a lot but the thing is you
can put that on you can put that kind of
weight on but be in shape you know that
yeah so but if you if I can see that
you're not you're that's not your
lifestyle yeah but like you could be in
shape but like I I've been bigger but
and I was still in shape like I was
doing CrossFit and stuff but I was
eating like [ __ ] and so it you can you
can be doing the exercises but if you're
eating like [ __ ] it doesn't matter but I
think that's what I mean I think that's
I think that's what it is it's like I
can see that you're not you're not in
control you're just eating like [ __ ]
although you're maybe a little bit
active you're not necessarily
structuring your body right yeah so yeah
I I guess what you're saying is like if
she's like actively like bodybuilding
and putting on weight productively but
if you're just 30 pounds of muscle yeah
that's what I'm saying so that's great
yeah
about that that's a lot that's why I
said once you start going past the 20
pounds Mark yeah sorry girls at College
we gained 10 20 pounds they'd be like
it's muscle because I was an athlete but
I'm like well you did not get like you
know how hard it is to gain 20 pounds of
muscle you freaking bodybuilder that's
what I'm saying like once it goes to go
that 20 that 20 it's like yeah you you
don't desire on me you don't actually
respect me yeah you're looking at me
you're looking at it like you don't rape
me yeah do you guys feel like that's a
form of disrespect absolutely kind of
yeah so you you give her 20. you're a
little more generous you give her 30.
you you're a little more generous
you know what I don't know if I could
actually say wait but what I do feel is
that if you ask your girlfriend to stop
putting on weight and she doesn't make
no effort at all to change something
then I feel like it's an issue so we
could see it for like that's a limit I
would say what
at least 10 yeah I know what he's saying
about this you can put on 10. you can
put on some crazy weight like that you
you can put on weight and still get 10
pounds is crazy 10 pounds it's crazy
yeah yeah yeah he said 10 15 10 kgs
guys the weight that she's already at
like from the way that you meet her like
that's what you're counting yeah 10
pounds is a bit in it 10 kg That's Heavy
bro
15 KGI you while in it's 20 kgs I just
don't understand why it's like you have
a man why wouldn't you try to keep him
right like in the clip
like you have a man why don't you try to
keep him I don't have no games
why are you like why are you only gonna
lose the weight after you guys break up
because they realize once as I said it's
like women have the same kind of like
you know like they say about men like
the notch is in our bed and whatever
women have their own thing too like you
are getting more sex than anybody in the
world you are the ones who are The
Gatekeepers to sex so when you realize
that it's like once you get a guy to
only focus on you and only spend your
time on you you go sour
treat a mean keep them Keen I never made
that up how can it come from me that
came from before I was born and it still
works to this day because the every time
I chase the girl down or you try to do
that extra air
second I turn my back on her and and
I'm out this restaurant with this thing
I'm going bowling with this girl I'm
watching wakanda with this one even
though I told you I was going to watch a
review and you see that oh now my
phone's ringing oh what are you doing
what are you doing this weekend what are
you doing tonight oh you want to know
what I'm doing because you see me doing
stuff but when I was paying you mine you
didn't want to hear me well you went to
uh what kind of forever with someone
else yeah Oh I thought you were gonna
watch that with me no you wasn't
available
okay let me let me get this I just want
to understand the situation so you're
with the girl and you're interested and
then she's curving you yeah so when I'm
paying attention she'll curve me she'll
curve and then you say you know what I'm
gonna move on yeah I'm I'm on the bigger
and better things absolutely and this
girl over here is interested so I'm
gonna go talk to her absolutely and
maybe she was a side chick that got
promoted
she came in through the right door she
didn't come in through the side chick
though she came in your favorite meals
there we go she started paying attention
she became a Kung Fu student
it's not a study in the art so she comes
in and then you take that attention away
now girl one comes back and says now I'm
interested now your side chick oh now
she's been devoted now you demoted
and that's how the Vicious Cycle goes
around so so in a way the side chick
could become the man
well no because the way he came into the
door to go that I didn't meet she was
just a complete random oh it was random
random I don't know what level of status
she was in with other her other
relationships but if you come in in the
same doorway You're Gonna Leave the
cycle
yeah but see I try to I try to offer the
main thing entrance to the first thing
and she denied it the door closed
forever membership close you're never
gonna get the main main chick treatment
ever again so now by the time he comes
back the only dude that's available for
her is side chick she's gonna take it
every time okay but why don't you take
it to begin with because she thought she
was entitled and she thought she she
thought I wasn't the price so so she
wasn't treating you like it came
absolutely so you treated her like a
peasant absolutely
right here
side door absolutely okay
okay so so you said roughly 20 he's the
most generous one here 30 pounds
hey what country are you from
Nigeria Jamaica okay that's why that's
why I had an extra 10 pounds
let me just clarify it
that is that is the that is the leeway
but it needs to come back down
how long does she have so she's she's at
30 almost 31 Pounds okay if if how long
she got to lose it
if there was no if there's no reason
other than you're eating in your
lifestyle shitty then really you've got
immediately you need this is you need to
I I know yeah because I I've had a
personal training past yeah so I know
how long it takes it would take with
with if you're really active and you
wanted to get it done yeah it would take
you maybe three months maybe to maybe
three months four months of proper like
regimented regime you see it you got me
so she's got three months
how much how much for you I don't know
about pounds but like uh 34 Stone of
course Max what's the difference
freestone's heavy three stones and
probably about the same to be honest uh
no you're the most generous one here
yeah
hey hey hey hey is your girlfriend
watching this show
okay now same question for the woman do
you think it's disrespectful if your man
lets himself go yes yes what do you
think
um depends on the circumstances okay
exactly you might be ill
okay outside of extreme circumstances
well if he's just been lazy and
then yeah I wouldn't say disrespectful
just just give me the ick okay I want to
feel disrespected personally I just
think ugh so what would give you the egg
is it a certain amount of weight
no I think it's the whole the laser
laziness element of it the sloth
it goes back to Lifestyle that whatever
they're eating like they've stopped
going to the gym they've stopped working
out they're they're eating lots of like
takeaways that's obviously making them
get fat that's gross that's gross it's
like it's the mindset like are you
are you just
not make an effort to do anything at all
like I can understand if you're working
really hard you'd have time you're
really tired blah blah but if you're
just at home all day every day playing
computer games
sitting around depressed like most men
yeah hold on let me let me ask a
question so say serious that's how
that's it that's how most men experience
life right now so are you gonna come and
motivate him or are you going to find
that other dude Who's got what you like
yeah how long does he have
three months
start to be more socially acceptable for
a man to be fat than it would a woman
it's almost frowned upon like oh my God
she's put on 30 pounds I mean you would
think women would be thinner than I mean
statistically men are thinner than women
like if that was true the woman would be
thinner
like if anything it's like it's more
socially acceptable for women to be
overweight because there's women's body
positivity people never frown upon men
putting on white but when women do it
it's like oh my God all the men are like
she's put on so much weight she's this
she's that but mine yeah they put her in
the they put him on the magazines yeah
magazines now the body but you don't see
men's body positivity that's just women
you don't say like the short man what
like the you know like there's no short
man body positivity movement nope
out here advocating for short men you're
broke shaming me
literally can I can I ask you so say say
for instance those um your your man was
uh he was earning uh 300 000 a year okay
but he was getting fat um
no I don't want him to get fat I can
provide for myself I don't care about
his money he ain't getting fat as long
as if if I know I can't get fat why
should he get fat fair enough it's as
simple as that what I'm hearing is is
the conditional money would hang about
with the belly basically
circumcision yeah you opened up the
portal because circumstances would
change now whether they can have a
Bailey or not or so this is awesome if I
was bringing home 300 Grand and I put on
40 pounds would you stay with me
absolutely no of course
I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll tell
you the difference though it's like what
women are attracted to men for their
like jobs their status like that sort of
thing but men don't care what you do for
a living so your money is nothing we're
like their money is something to us from
the beginning like I said men are born
without value we have to build our
status from about five we know from
about five years old we have to make
something of ourselves women are born
with value you can just show up and
somebody is going to help you out
it's like if you ask for a time in the
street versus iOS for the time in the
street it's going to be a lot harder
because women are just naturally
accepted in society for most things
women and children first like we know
this this is what we encounter have been
raised on so it's different for us it's
always going to be different that's why
you see fat Rich Italian Mafia bosses
with slim pretty ass wives and they make
sure they stay in the gym and look good
because they know a heartbeat they can
be replaced by the 21 22 23 year old I
don't give a cat don't care about your
old ass I mean look at like Donald Trump
Melinda exactly she's not with him for
love
she's with him because he owns Real
Estate in Manhattan I will say that some
some some
um guys do like uh it when women put on
weight they do like it but it's normally
not for a woman it's normally not the
guy that you want you know I mean
yeah it's nobody not the guy that you
want that wants you at that moment you
know what I mean uh what's it called I
think a lot of guys
the one that's always behind the bins
that likes Helga but know what the hell
go don't want him Helga want Arnold and
there's my man with the braces and that
he's the one yeah that's the one you
that's the guy you're talking about
well it's like a mating strategy because
like men I can't remember I'm probably
butchering this but like men are
predispositioned to like want to spread
their seed as much as possible and if
they can't get the women that are the
most like fruitful or like the most
fertile the most young the most whatever
they it's a mating strategy like that
your brain like programs you to find
more women attractive like when men look
to qualify women look to disqualify
[Music]
yeah so it's like oh yeah her face looks
like she got hit by a train but you know
big boobs
that's how people be getting online I
don't even see why you wit it and she
stands up and walks off man would be
like oh yeah okay I see you bro I can't
understand it I get it all right
Blessing video number three
video number three
you're working at home the point is
there is no accountability for men so
when we talk about but when we talk
about these side chicks the first thing
we want to do is look at the woman I've
been that woman that look at a side
chick and be like uh how could you do
that but the realest it is how could you
look at your [ __ ] every night and say
how much you love her how could you post
your how could you marry a woman yeah a
child with a woman do all this and hold
your woman up to this high standard
because I'd never see the funniest thing
is this will sit up here and talk about
strippers terrible prostitutes terrible
but fun they're good girls you just
decides you'd never be my main as if
that's some type of reward your Mains
being cheated on disrespected degraded
and you're putting your main in danger
in the line to be having STDs and some
and being completely and totally torn
and broken apart so there's no homework
or side chick if you both you vote
[Music]
so what'd you guys think about
she sounds like a side chick that didn't
make it to the main
what do you think should go a point to
be fair I think it depends on the
relationship though like again if like
if it's a secless marriage
difficult to expect the Mantis to stay
in that sad situation but if your
woman's doing everything for you
do you think most men will look for a
side chick if she's doing everything
she's supposed to do
nah but
usually those are the guys that just
have a lot of women throwing themselves
at them so it's a lot more difficult to
be biting them away so I might slip
through the correction I mean I mean
should she expect monogamy if she picks
a guy that has women throwing themselves
at them at him all the time should she
expect that
no
no
absolutely no I think monogamy is a lie
like if you date an NBA player are you
going to be shocked when you get cheated
on no no
why do women all want that percentage of
God this is what I mean this is what
confuses me because I'm like you know
this is what you're gonna get you know
you're not gonna get that and this is
why I realized what I feel is that most
women in like today
when they get into a quote-unquote
relationship 99 of them are settling
because they're saying to themselves
right I don't think this guy is out here
getting all the girls that's what
they're really saying I think I can pin
this one down and keep him under wraps
because that's what they're really
saying to themselves because the guy
that they know who is getting all the
girls they don't even bother
they don't even bother because they know
they don't look like they've Rihanna's
and the hot city girls and all the girls
that are promoted on Instagram they know
they don't match up to those which is
what the guys at the top are promoting
as the style of women that they want
because if the rich guys started
promoting the women that dress like they
did in the 50s with core sets and not
showing no skin
you would see the hot girl summer dry up
as fast as winter because you know what
they want protection provision and peas
they want to get flown yeah but there's
different type of like if you looked at
politicians wives they're usually not a
really promiscuous and they don't
usually have their ass on Instagram and
that sort of thing it's just like women
look at the NBA players the rappers the
entertainers like the people that they
pick but that's a very
like it like one they're not really good
long-term security bets because a lot of
them go bro like fast money like what do
they say fast money comes with slow
problems so if you get money quick a lot
of times it goes quick too
um and like it's just interesting
because a lot of people will say like
the Kim K's of the world that's such a
small group of society where if you look
at like politicians business owners like
they don't want a girl that has a bunch
of work done in her ass out on Instagram
like I grew up around a lot of these men
that's not who they pick and that's
because they don't but they're not the
ones who are influencing everybody yeah
because you're right because it's a
small again it always seems to be a
small percentage of people that are
controlling the majority of what's going
on I mean take Melinda Melinda Trump
right I mean I you know I'm not I'm not
trying to go in the Trump conversation
but just an example of a politician's
wife she doesn't ever ask on Instagram
like she's very classy
or even chilled what's his name Joe
Biden's wife Jill Biden I think Kimberly
or Michelle Obama like none of them and
they also from a different generation
too I think men want classy yeah yeah
100 that's what they want they don't
want their their partners are so on
Instagram or boobs out or or anything
like that why would they want that why
do you think so many girls were are
flying to different countries to get
bbls
because it's cheaper yeah it's cheaper
yeah I didn't mean why why not why are
they doing it in the first place oh why
are they doing it
right the competition it's literally a
trend and a track for the attention
fashion thing because you go back
however many years ago you didn't find
girls getting their lips done now all of
a sudden it's fashionable to have bigger
lips same with
um the way like fashion has progressed
throughout the the decades a certain era
it would be fashionable to wear dresses
and skirts and stuff like that now it's
not like that to have your hair a
certain way so I think it's a fashion
thing girls do it to keep up with the
fashion the latest Trend it's a mixture
of fashion and laziness like women that
get bbos because they're too lazy to go
to the gym it's cheating he's cheating
they want to say you know everyone's she
doesn't think you've got to understand
the difference between a player I was
having this conversation earlier
a cheetah is a guy that's going to tell
you you're the only person you're the
only one I'm dealing with is just you
babe that's what she would do a player
would tell you your Monday
and don't call me on Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday because that's
not your day I think actually what it is
is is because men lie that's what it is
we don't lie we lie because we told to
lie no no no we we we lie and we will we
will make uh women feel like that is
what we want
yeah and that's that that could be the
only that is the only reason yeah but
yeah but but it is literally for for a b
that's it
that's the only reason I can think of
okay that that the the masses of women
are going out there doing like trying to
have this same look you see what this
BBL look because it's a cheat that's
what I'm saying it's cheating it's it's
men
those kind of girls though they get
confused with like sexual attention and
like real attention so they think the
victim because guys sleep with them
because they've got a bbo they didn't
get confused I just think modern women
are lazy because you can type into
Google how to build a bigger butt at the
gym
it would be pretty easy to come on
it's laziness but they think that that's
what guys want but in reality all they
want is just a bang I mean guys do want
a fat ass that's what I'm saying it's
just like you're doing a real one though
yeah yeah I asked I've asked her I'm
curious fake butt no but a girl with no
butt or a fake butt what would you
picking no but no but no but no but
you're right it depends on what it looks
like because if because some of it some
of his asses are wild that some of these
asses are donkey I don't know like
what's going on but if it's a
a subtle job
subtle job you know it's like widening
of the hips like you know you know I'm
you know I mean like bubble then all
right cool we could work most attractive
women with bbls are celebrities is what
I realize and then a lot of people that
have that are just normal people that
have done it it just never looks like a
clowns
if you don't have the value that comes
with the stardom and the TV and all of
that and the lifestyle then it doesn't
even work yeah it doesn't fit in a BBF
or boss man at the corner shop like what
does it fit yeah
like who's really gonna see you when
that you went out that one time because
you got invited by a rapper to come to a
table like unless you're one of the tape
girls or one of the girls that's on the
tables at table set and on the circuit
where they know what they're doing what
are you actually what would you think of
a previous guy bought her the BPL
bring those back yeah that's you bring
those back man yeah wow
does this come with warranty no way
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats um guys like the video um
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push these live streams
out there are
1926 people watching and only 500 likes
that is an atrocity an atrocity there
should be at least a thous at least half
of you should have liked this stream
okay an atrocity like the video
um okay also guys we have our membership
tiers if you want to be a part of the
chat today make sure you sign up for our
first membership tier and our four and
our fourth membership tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
also guys go follow my Instagram it's
just pearly things one they took away my
old one they also took away my first
second third and fourth Tick Tock
account so go
um follow my fifth and sixth Tick Tock
account just probably things top five
okay so um
men know there is a burden of
performance for us if we smoke live at
home and live our home live at home with
our parents broken fat Society tells us
we are losers Society coddles women
today
um Matt butcher women don't compete
these ladies are so not used to being
called out on their BS that they can't
respond coherently ladies watch yourself
on the show and take notes
um Gus
where men succeed in life we purchase
cars good homes nice clothes watches
chains
Etc to attract the right women we know
how to compete a boss babe in her late
20s and so on has been lied to by
feminism and society and been turned
into the masculine independent man they
always want to marry Edgar Rays thank
you for the Super Chat snake was right
do you respect side dudes oh that's a
good I might ask that in a second mgtow
by Logic I'm so sick of women saying
they deserve their Christian Gray
Anastasia was a virgin you morons
Michelle Karis pillow on the lap is
always a red flag low confidence so they
try to cover up monshins is your baby
worth your career since you got pregnant
when you finished college and right
before you entered the workforce your
husband has an excellent job would you
still want to focus on your career zero
Fallout being a stay-at-home mom for the
majority of the time is wrong most were
poor working class that is why they were
a fit after kids they helped with the
farmer during the Gathering and the food
prep they still came home and listened
to their man
um I'm going to ask this was a good
question
is a baby worth your career would you
say
no no
so you wouldn't ever give up your career
for a child
no I would do both
okay I would like to think that if I
have obviously I don't have kids at the
moment but if I had kids in the future I
would I would still keep my career
because I want to progress
yeah so um how many hours a week do you
work
60 plus 60 plus 65 hours a week yeah
probably so who who would watch the kids
I would have to pay for child care okay
so you would want to pay someone else to
raise your kids
um I don't think they would all
obviously
yeah I don't I think they would always
be raising them they would technically I
mean 65 hours a week they would
hopefully your man's working as well so
maybe I would cut down my hours but I
won't give my career up for the child no
way I'd I'd still like to progress in
doing that I'd like to think that I
could provide for that child as well
would you be okay with the the man not
working
no if I'm working he's got work too my
funny Stanton
because we both need to provide if I'm
working however many hours a week 40 or
I can't have a house husband and look
after the kids yeah
[Laughter]
what if he earns enough money to look
after you the kids would you stand up
yeah but what if he leaves or if he left
what if he stands to take off he could
do but it's 50 50 isn't it so no I'm I
mean you ever did you go to college
um did you graduate no okay 70 to 80
chance so there's only uh like 20 to 30
chance he leaves
so it's like most likely that you would
leave not him
mom's still gonna still gonna progress
in my career even if there was more
chance of me leaving than him I wouldn't
expect him to give up work as I wouldn't
either because if I expected him to give
up work and there's more chance of me
leaving what is he gonna do do you think
that's selfish
to not give up work yeah like then like
what about the kids you neglect the
children I mean yeah you should have
kids yeah and it's more likely that
um someone outside of the home could
abuse a child
like a lot of kids get to be I mean
there's horror stories that people DM me
of like getting abused at daycare and
like by nannies and like that sort of
thing like you're opening your child up
that could still happen even if I'm not
working it's a lot less likely if you
are not necessarily because if the
person let's say the person
um doing the abusing was a family member
you know like you hear you know
unquestion stuff like that I know I've
I've only got to take my child to see
their Uncle once a week for that to
happen it doesn't matter whether I'm
working or not that stuff can still
happen I I know but you wouldn't say
like it would be less likely if you were
there see 65 hours remember yeah I'm
saying I would cut it down okay let's
let's cut it down to 40. yeah that's
still full that's still full time yeah
yeah
but I don't think the child's going to
be on the ends with the gangs
the possibility of abuse is any larger
just because I am at work so and I have
a question so you put yourself in do you
want to be married
yeah so you put yourself in the guy's
point of view what what does he get from
a wife that's working all the time if
he's making money your money's nothing
to him
so what would he and he doesn't get a
mother why would he marry you
we are building a life together though
I'd still like to think that I would be
a mother because I'm also trying to
provide for our children making sure we
have better things together so like for
example if what I'm saying you can't you
can't say anything with your career and
your money because if a guy if a guy has
money so all of my brothers they make
six figures all of them and they don't
give a [ __ ] about a girl's money
like it's nothing to them because they
have money
so you can't
save money anything else
because most guys then they get married
they want a mother for their children
but if you're not going to be the mother
what do they get I'd still be a mother I
don't think me working stops me being a
mother like
no way it absolutely does no my sister
and her boyfriend they've got one child
together they both still work she
doesn't work like a full-time or finish
his work at like three or what not she's
still a mother to her child does it
that's her does the part does her
partner make six figures no if he made
six figures do you think she would pay
for a thing
pay for a child care do you pay do you
think she would be paying for anything
if her partner was making six figures
no the answer is no and you can't this
is actually uh the more um so I'm
opening a wife's school soon so if you
ever if you if you're a three or four
and you want to be a wife sign up for my
score
not not me I'm not a wife but I've been
talking to like women like I've talked
to this woman who fostered 10 children
um and like she's like a homemaker and
um
she said she raised 10 kids on less than
10 000 a year and like but most people
refuse to move out of the city because
they want the lifestyle
so I mean like a lot of [ __ ] like she
was saying that a lot of people like
think you need two incomes but they just
like want to eat out they want new
clothes they want like like imagine it's
about their lives yeah
I think naturally with that lifestyle
come slightly better things and
opportunities as well if you look at a
child whose um parents are potentially
living in poverty against a child whose
parents are making a bit of money
they've got better things for school
um better opportunities when they're
older you know maybe their parents can
buy their first car and so on whereas
the other child hasn't got that straight
away which is one thing you can't buy
which is time which is time and teaching
so the T So for that child I think uh my
I would want to teach that child and if
it's not necessarily me doing full time
because I might be at work I would want
someone who I am but what if what if I'm
working whilst a child's at school I
pick the child up from school I can't be
a mother to him at school that's
different that's after that I mean yeah
I think that's most people would be fine
with that but when they're under the age
of five and even if it's after school
that's I don't think that's 40 hours a
week because what is it they get to
school at nine they stop at what 2 30.
yeah you'll be working part-time at that
point really
I definitely just wouldn't give up a
career I want to ask sorry quickly what
is a definition of a career
what jobs are we actually talking about
here
when you say career
it's real that's a good question as in
what jobs do I see as a career yeah like
if you say career what would you what
what kind of what profession
um
depends I guess it depends really it
could be on many professions I.E like
um a lady could be a hairdresser but see
that as a career because she's doing
really well in it I think it depends you
can't say that just because they're
working at so and so that's not a career
I mean I I can you think cutting hair is
more important than being a mother
I can absolutely that say that cutting
hair is not more important than being a
mom than raising your kids and being
there you never know you've used my
chains once you have a kid ah listen
when you're a kid you're going to be a
full-time you have a kid you become a
full-time hairdresser automatically
automatically so it's like there's
nothing greater than you can gift the
world than life itself
there's nothing better than that as a
woman that's why you get blessed to be a
woman we as men started off as women in
the theaters and deformed into what we
are now everything starts as a female
everything that's more expensive in the
world as a female why because it can
create it can procreate and if you take
away your the value of your creation you
take away the value of your eggs you
take away the value of your ovaries you
lost the feminism because feminism all
they are is a bunch of women who want to
be the F boys that they say they hate
they want to sleep if you're ready one
of his sleep with they want to work out
all the jobs that men are working at
they want to walk around with no clothes
on no shirts and [ __ ] on they want to
become the men that they say they hate
and in the mix of it they finesse women
out of all of your benefits
what about you would you give up your
career for kids yeah yeah I would why
um because I think having choosing to
have a kid is is selfish anyway it's so
like it's a decision that you've chosen
to make to bring a child into the world
so you're responsible for that child
you're responsible for nurturing that
child and being there and
if
you don't think if it's done right it's
the most selfless thing you can do I
mean in terms of like for the the child
doesn't have a choice
in coming into world you make that
decision right okay so it's selfish okay
I mean you make message so if you're not
in a position to have a child or you
want to work 70 hours a week that's not
fair on the child you're not there for
them they they're not they're not being
nurtured or cared for in the way that
they need
um so yeah I would if I chose to have a
kid and the only way to
be there for my kid is to give up my job
because after they've gone to school I
can build my career back up
so it's not like I can once I've left I
can never go back and that's it I can
build my career back up or find a way to
work around my children would you give
up lifestyle for kids
for a family
yeah okay
yeah I would so like no no eating out no
I don't care about those things no new
clothes no nothing yeah I mean I would
too yeah yeah I'm quite a simple person
at the core of it so yeah
um
oh this was a good one
back to the side chicks
do you guys respect side dudes
absolutely have you ever been a side
dude I'm currently
um
[Music]
what's that like it's great okay tell me
tell me about it conversations are great
because now we can talk about the main
dude like I like that's how I do music
and like I even one of my balls I say
you took a Nobu I hated one team one
time he come quick like fast food
because you will spend like I said the
90 dudes will spend their hard earned
paper their hard-earned hours taking you
out to dinners giving you all the
attention making you feel good about
yourself telling you good morning
darling and ground rising and giving you
all the morning taxes and she's going to
come and see me after
because I'm not giving it none of that
energy that's not what I'm here for how
did you meet her how did I meet her
um how did you slide out like did she
have a man when you met her
um I didn't ask I don't ask there's no
need to ask because women know before
like you have like this
natural pheromone thing in your mind
where you can actually pick up to see if
a guy is sleeping with a lot of girls
with free isn't so when I approached her
I think I actually met her in the street
when I approached the
I think I was just doing my work like
because I'd be like promoting my music
out and about every day and stuff so I
pulled up on it and we just started
talking just having conversations and
then at one day the conversation just
went from
here to there like it took an a left
turn but sometimes you know where you
whereas men you take that risk be like
all right I'm gonna cross the line now
and and talk in that direction and if
she entertains it I don't need to ask
any more questions and it went from
there and now it's like we have a cool
relationship where it's like she would
be telling me about other dudes or she
was out with this guy the other day and
we can just have an open chat I've been
talking about girls that I'll be with
because well she got multiple side dudes
yeah she's got multiple dudes because
women in the top 10 percent because as
much as we look at the men and we focus
on the men ten percent there's a top 10
of women too this is why the beauty
industry is worth so much this is why
modeling and fashion because women
compete as much as they say they don't
want to that's why when you go to the
shopping centers it's mainly women
mannequins in the windows because
they're checking each other out they're
competing against each other so the top
10 of women are getting all the
attention from the men because men are
always going to punch above their weight
and women know if they're dealing with a
top 10 10 type guy or or a 90 type guy
and the night expense guy is going to
pay for everything
and the top 10 guy ain't paying for
nothing was going to get everything and
that's just how the deal has been set
same thing it works the same way for
women and for men top 10 of women so the
other guys like taking around real dates
and all this stuff and like courting her
and then you're just smashing after
pretty much
like literally like are they in a
relationship like actual relationship I
don't know if they're in a relationship
have you guys ever done that
have you ever gone on a date with one
guy and hooked up with a different one
after
yes yeah yeah why
normal uh
[Laughter]
um because I guess the first one isn't
like a main
and you just sort of keeping your
options open working out what you want
so it's kind of like the
the guy after you already knew him and
you're like getting to know the the one
that's taking you on the dates yeah or
you might know both and you might just
be thinking I'm just could be date three
at the moment there's already nine bills
why didn't you sleep with the guy you
went on the date with
because he courted you right
yeah
that's the ones that they don't want
they didn't go well
you spent way too much money there's
something that I learned I don't think
you
have to
I don't think you have to take a girl
out to get to get that I don't think
that's true
for actual information right it doesn't
mean that we're going home to my house
tonight to sleep together absolutely not
do you think that
um it's true that nice guys finish last
by that because the guy that actually
took you on the date didn't get some but
the guy who didn't did
um
not always I think that women although
we like to think we like a bad boy deep
down we actually want someone to just
treat us nice do nice things the the bad
boys always all fun and games until you
actually want to settle down I think the
goal for you lot is to get the bad boy
to do nice things for you that's you
lots gold that's you lots kick oh he's a
bad boy but he's nice to me
no I don't think you want to ask me for
my number my boyfriend's a killer
like that's what you like I mean violent
offenders have more children than um
felons have more kids than non-felons
you could say we have good taste in men
you could say women pick well you know
what I'm realized as well one thing I've
learned of something that I've always
been taught as well someone has told me
a woman told me this is that if a woman
doesn't sleep with you in her mind
multiple times more than three or four
times you will never see it in real life
I don't care what you give you could buy
a house car
and the thing is you know what's so
crazy
um Eddie Murphy's been saying this from
like dilemma like back in the day when
he was wearing leather suits you've been
saying the same thing he got his wife
from Africa brought it to America she
went in half now yeah you get me because
she's hanging around westernized women
in the East they understand the value of
a man's provision they they respect it
women don't respect it anymore because
they've been given their own
independence but biologically in nature
is clashing with that and you don't
understand why yeah you're earning all
this money but you still want to be
submissive so you've got to kind of pick
a side that's why being a side dude in
the modern world is great it's great
yeah it's like it's like Tinder and
hinge and all these things with me I'm
curious hands who's been a side dude
hands hands up yeah yes
why did I think I was gonna go this way
is it gonna be great because most men
talk about oh I don't want to stir
another man's porridge do you like that
is that nice okay
there's no way like I understand like
you can bang a girl that's got a
boyfriend but
bro I'm doing you a favor I'm doing you
a favor I'm hoping we get caught hold on
when you say when you say regularly see
who what do you mean you're her side
dude like she's got her boyfriend that
she sees all the time and she calls you
up for sex that's probably because
they're not having sex
that's why you're the same I'm saying so
as a man that I don't read that like I
would never be that guy it will it will
have to work at my convenience if that
was the case it's not going to be a case
where you're just going to call me from
anywhere and I'm gonna drop what I'm
doing but I mean we'll have to it will
have to work at my convenience
um I men would do anything like honestly
in reality you would never know
this is why I'm saying women have are
the best at being sneaky you would never
ever ever know I was the side dude
that's the that's the beauty but you
know I know that's what I'm saying are
you like so when I shake your hand and
say what's up bro hey nice to meet you
but we've got regardless if he knows you
know that's what I'm saying yeah so
that's the problem so you're right we're
staring another man's party I'm not
stirring no one else you are she just
made another Bowl
porridge that would be me taking her out
that would mean me buying her stuff
his porridge like she couldn't she might
be telling you yeah she might be telling
you no we ain't sleeping together we
ain't having sex and then you were
banging her that day she wouldn't tell
me that because you just said yourself
girls are so good at being sneaky yeah
you don't understand as the side dude
you get let into certain information so
she'll let me know oh he's coming around
tonight you don't know I don't know
anything I don't know any guy that
really cares if another guy is sleeping
with a girl like this is what so we
don't I don't care like so what it's
only if you're taking her seriously yeah
yeah exactly I mean if it's someone I'm
trying to take seriously then I don't
want no one around it but if if I know
that so you know so you know this girl
is leaving her yard that she's with her
man they could have just had sex and
she's coming to see you
and you're gonna yeah
if I'm seeing if I'm single and I'm
mingling yeah I don't know I don't care
what you have to understand is most
girls have somebody else there three
even that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about a woman that's in a
relationship and you're her side but
that's no this is what I'm saying this
is what we're talking you can't be
saying that you you don't do fingers you
don't because you know you know they
sort of saying you know you're the side
guy she's got her man and she's calling
you up every now and then to have sex
how could you be okay with that in
yourself like that because I think in my
mind is just been released
I don't understand like how you could
like enjoy that you know what I mean why
does it have to be on the same day and
all of that yeah
yeah well I mean if she's in a
relationship
I mean there are a decent amounts that
are sexless but but I mean she's
probably screwed him that week
yeah but again why is she coming to me
because man ain't hearing it right every
girl has got that dude the one dude that
made you nut that one dude exists in
your phone you know where he's at you
know where he exists you know exactly
where to find him you know what to say
if you call him so let's not play him
because it's a big risk for girls when
they take because like most most dudes
don't even know that women don't even
ejaculate from penetration
they completely Miss they completely
Miss foreplay but on the side dude that
knows that but listen she's calling I
can't relate you get it I can't relate
no I'm not saying everyone
single I'll have enough girls there that
I know that are submitting just to me
you could tell yourself that bro I know
you can believe that all you want to but
if you know if this is what it is if now
that what would make that true is that
those girls were five sixes and sevens
not necessarily because if you know the
game seven eights nines and tens don't
have one dude and if you believe that
you're playing yourself yeah obviously
but so you have to accept what I'm
talking about is a woman that's in a
relationship doesn't matter you're the
side dude I understand
I understand what you're saying
it's not about wanting to be that guy
because once it's happened what were you
gonna do that's what I'm saying a
banging that girl I see the girl
boyfriend that's one thing okay but if
you're then her side dude continuously
at what stage
at what stage do you become the side
dude what is how many how many times do
you go back
she's going on moms no no
I need to know how many times because
just if we're just smashing then I'm
never the side dude in a sense based on
what you're saying because you're saying
it as if like I'm doing more than that
that's all that she comes to me for do
you guys ever get nervous that like that
because you know people get killed over
this [ __ ] like what if the guy finds out
and comes to your house or something you
ever get nervous a guy comes if a guy is
is is uh that emotional that he would go
and look for the the guy he was never
repeat then he then that's just
foolishness that's foolish he was never
a place to check his he needs to check
his girl exactly don't check don't hate
that don't hate the player hate the game
bro
most most like violent killings happen
over women
it's the majority at a time it's all
over again yeah and I said what a girl
would entertain a lot a lot of the time
it's over again
I think maybe most of the time it's
usually over money that's what I was
thinking like women but anyone for
anyone who's killing somebody over over
women again it's not you're not pee
you're not that guy and this is what the
problem is there's a lot of people
coming out and talking about interaction
and experiences with women and they have
no experience with women if you weren't
getting gal in the park if you aren't
getting gallowan cinema tickets were two
pounds yeah if you weren't taking behind
the alleyway when you didn't have no
bread you are not the guy to be talking
about gal because you got a bit of bread
wait wait wait wait wait
it don't make sense
if you're not the guy
but that's taking girls in the alleyway
if you're not the guy who was getting
girls as a young dude the pretty girls
without money because when you're young
you ain't got though so when I'm saying
when I'm saying about the alleyway the
park these are the stories that these
pretty girls that you would call a 10
now want to clean ourselves a ten these
are the skeletons in their closet that
they have with the top 10 of guys that
became the top 10 guys because like you
said it's only a small amount of guys
that are sleeping with everybody and
they've been doing that forever do you
see what I'm saying those same
percentage of guys that you're talking
about they didn't just start sleeping
with everyone they've been doing it from
a young age okay okay but let me just go
back to it and you would take them in
the alleyway
on the roof
on the roof we was young who's got money
for Airbnb and hotels when you're 16 and
17. I think I know what you're talking
about when you're 16 and 17. I think at
that age at that at that age at that age
in the woods you know no but you know
why it was at that age is because you
you didn't you didn't want to take him
back to your mom's yard
you had to you
I understand see what I'm saying so if
he wasn't that guy
now coming into your you know mid-20s
and 30s because you got a bit of Finance
this is where you're going to struggle
this is where you're going to get simp
because you don't think you've been told
by society that you have to pay X Y and
Z and do all of these things in order to
get access to a woman's body but woman
will tell you ain't gonna do nothing
like I said I'm the dude that will pull
up in a string vest shorts on a BMX and
take her
while you just got out and you may pay
for the rent all you've got the rent out
you got the Airbnb you got the hotel but
she doesn't desire you here if she
doesn't want you here you're never going
to get it in real life man
you think that's true
silence is enough thank you no okay why
what he's saying is that like because
you've been doing it since you were kids
that now you are like the
the master player but I find most guys
who do a lot of that young they actually
don't know their way around a woman's
body because all they've learned is just
the smash and then they think in their
mind they're great because they've had
loads of girls but they're really not so
they're like delusional yeah oh okay
well I mean you could say it's delusion
but I mean if I didn't say you're
delusional I just said no no no
generally no I'm saying you could say
it's delusion but it's logic if you've
been just because you get loads of girls
don't mean you're good so he's worked on
he's worked on quantity
you don't think if a guy okay you're
okay I just have a question you don't
think of a guy that's trying to apply
for the NBA and he's made a lot of shots
doesn't make you good oh so so quit it's
all right so why do you go some people
have a natural Talent yeah so they can
apply for the and then naturally be
great and some people and some people
have to do work but even some people up
play or do all the work don't make the
cut
so on Snapchat put out the Queen's
funeral
wild
it's true like you have to think about
it if you've done something what
at the Queen's funeral hell yeah Lizzy's
loving it Lizzy went to go and see her
husband bro Liz he's a g I'll ever get
twisted bro what do you mean bro
send off
one you would never be able to say you
did that ever again that's like that's
one for the books do you guys think he's
right about
um girls having one guy they always go
back to
you
yes don't try and deny it that's your
facial expression alone
I don't think that that's just because
he's got so much experience in banging
girls I don't think that that's not just
in banging you there's always a guy that
you go back to in between your
relationships because you know that just
like press the buttons no it's because
you know he's available at any time you
you know at any time
you can just call him and he'll come
back he did it sidemen all over the guy
everywhere the biggest podcast on in UK
right now of KSL what are they called
sidemen
wow because people want to be PC and
politically correct for the internet but
in reality
in the truth when you are on that Ray
and nephew and you think do I go home or
do I catch this 15 pound Uber to his
crib so is it fair to say women create
these sidemen or help the situation
because you just said you go back to a
guy several times in different
relationships so this is over a span of
six four years six years this is it
could be women what's that women's
controller what's the longest you've
gone back to a guy how many years
so I don't have to meet random new
people let's go back to someone I don't
know just familiar he's a familiar
convenient would you guys rather have a
girl with a higher body count or a guy
that she goes back to in between
relationships
say that again would you rather have a
girl with a higher body count or a girl
with a guy that she goes back to in
between relationships
um I would I would say a higher body
count for the question only only for the
question only because you're saying
about being in a relationship right
like you said that dude owns her he owns
her soul he owns your soul
listen the devil doesn't need to be with
you to own yourself yeah this is this is
your soul is mine yeah this is this is
this is why it's so hard to make a woman
this is why it's so hard to please a
woman because the second you do it right
she is yours if a girl was in front of
you but what you're saying is that he's
doing it right like he's doing it so
amazing that I have to keep coming back
I've just told you it's a person of
convenience
so he was not the best sex you've ever
had no if he's like a person of
convenience so someone that I know that
I can if I'm single I can call you what
about you
have I done that how long
uh six years six years wow so this is
not what they're saying it is really the
Inside Man stuff
assignments wait wait wait wait wait
wait so how um would you say was he the
best sex you've ever had yes okay I
think so I wouldn't have called him a
side man no that's not a definition is
he an ex-boyfriend yes okay so why
aren't you with him
um
because of Lifestyle
okay because he's taking more than one
Soul because us sidemen like to collect
Souls what do you mean like he doesn't
make enough
no as in he
wants to go out every weekend and
collect souls and stuff like that I'm
not interested in that like I don't want
someone who's partying every weekend no
thank you because there's a high
opportunity there's a high possibility
go and get whatever girl you want
because if I wanted you I'd still have
you no see women it's sad that women
played a role of that person for six
years playing this game with them and
they still complain about a lifestyle
and this and that but fed into that same
ego anyway well I didn't because I
wasn't his girlfriend I was just someone
who never thought he played role of his
girlfriend I'm just gonna like from the
men's point of view it's like it
women like we want relationships men
want sex so you're giving him what he
wants without getting anything from it
so it's like you're playing into him
being a player and like having multiple
women because you keep going back
and I'm not like judging you for it it's
just like that's how the guys see it and
I mean it kind of makes sense you know
what I mean yeah they've got it perfect
from their their point of view and I get
that but if if I wanted a relationship
with him I could have been in a
relationship like wow sorry what we
control the relationship no we couldn't
we determine who is wifey that is the
only Power left did he ask you to be his
girlfriend
he said during it yeah like I think that
that we can be together and I was like
nah okay so he said I want you to be my
girlfriend and then you said no um okay
um
why because of his lifestyle I'm not
interested in that lifestyle just for
sex though that lifestyle was good
yeah but it's not just about sex is it
what I want as as a future it's not just
sex so that was great and convenient but
it's not all I want okay
would you take what you want
over sex though
yeah what if a guy had everything you
wanted but bad sex
yeah um no no no no no and I repeat side
men own the soul do you think I know do
you think like we're sold a dream
like you can't have everything so it's
like we want a guy that's good at sex
good career but also good at sex but
doesn't talk to a bunch of girls to get
good at sex
tall makes good money yeah and and we
don't want to compete for them
yes I don't have that many stipulations
like you don't need to be six foot and
I'm quite thingy I'm like chilled what's
your what's your what are your standards
I don't have like oh you don't need to
earn more than me you don't need to be
tall and be okay whatever I don't I just
like individuals for who they are like
[Music]
um
20 000 pounds a year you're dating them
yeah really
yeah twenty thousand I've lived by
myself like since I was 17 I've looked
after myself so you don't I don't really
need anything from you okay so so your
course low income yeah I don't mind yeah
okay yeah I don't know what I need for
it I don't prefer
um bums but you definitely
um yeah but not everyone just has a come
up not everyone's gonna be 50 Grand 100
Grand a year just like that and I
understand that because I've been
someone who has been on a low income and
I've had to work really hard some people
have to work extra hard I'm saying like
he's stuck at it's not like he's gonna
get better it's like he's at that for
Life yeah but then he can be the house
husband and I can go to work that's why
I mean that's the least yeah you're
compromising on something yeah but it's
just like and I mean that's probably why
you're that's why I say individual to
this the person because someone could be
on a low income but if I if I'm the
higher earner and he's happy to stay
home and be the stay-at-home dad and
have the kids then it's the win wins
because I still get my career he gets to
look after the kids
would you guys do that be a house
husband no wait no way
all right I see that well it depends
he's like maybe it depends for a time of
your life you know you might have to be
at home what's wrong with that it's not
wrong
for a portion yeah for a portion that
might not be it might not be too bad but
if a house has been like suggests that
you that is what you do know
that is it that is the only thing that
you're doing no for for the foreseeable
future you're raising these Jokers
raising children is is a long term it's
a long-term commitment so we're talking
about
maybe until that child is able to film
for themselves kind of when they go
secondary school that kind of time no if
we're talking about being a house
husband up until then I don't know about
that I don't think that the woman would
look at you you're asking to make it
they're gonna look that that we're
asking for it your woman's gonna look at
you like you're a [ __ ] absolutely
where's my dinner
like why why are the kids asleep that's
an ego thing isn't it though absolutely
it's like Power Balance and how yes yes
you have your relationship with that
person so it's individual no you're
talking about exceptions to the rule as
men hell no no no no no we're not even
yeah
that's what I'm saying so biologically
we couldn't even deal with it like our
level of tolerance as much I know a lot
of um House people house husbands how
many oh and I know a lot of men who are
the um main caregivers of their kids
more than five
yeah you know more than five yeah it's
interesting because women make less than
men and we spend more so we're not
really good with money I don't think
most women would do well as the head of
household
they don't a lot of people like my
friends
um who she's a lawyer and I can't
remember what her husband died and when
they decide to have kids he stayed home
and she's because she was the higher
earner so it financially worked better
for them no and that's uh if I'm I'm all
for people who should do what they want
to do so if that works for them but it's
just the number one reason that people
get divorced and women tend to leave men
after they out earn them and one of the
another indicator that you're going to
get divorced is that like a woman gets a
promotion at work
well people are just superficial what
can I say
I don't know if it's superficial I think
it's in our biology partially in biology
yeah yeah yeah it's like the world is
trying to argue with like God's nature
but you can't argue with that you just
can't
even in like if you look at you take it
to the world if you ever get stuck when
the world was created there wasn't money
though so of course it was it was trade
we have trade money would you guys this
currency is what we as human beings
decide currency is so back in the day if
I had 50 wives which they used to have
but no cattle and and and and scoop over
there had a hundred cattle I mean like
bro Shanika shanicho I'll be getting on
my nerves for the last six months take
them and give me some of those cows and
that's trade that's currency that's how
we used to get things going back in the
day that's how it was this is why you
would hear about biblical men having a
thousand wives you weren't smashing a
thousand of them what it was is that
they were connected to his name which
provided status power and protection
would you guys give up monogamy for a
guy that if you were really into a guy
it's like long term
where you know he could step out from
time to time
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately yeah yeah it's been a
like you're the main chick but just you
know every now and again he steps out
possibly I don't know no why why you're
already the side chick that's what I
think in the guy you're sleeping with
like are you ready or he's not
monogamous so I'm either side chick or
am I the man no you're the man
every now and then he can go and yeah
screw us out chick maybe not not even a
concubine
no way so how come she was the side
chick before
why was that aside yeah yeah if you're
happy to be the side chick because I
wasn't getting hurt okay but it's so
interesting to me because I'm just like
if I was gonna be a side chick I would
try to be the main chick
like how how to have been the main chick
I just chose not because the girl told
me of why it doesn't make no sense you
know what I think we don't want it if
I'm okay
no I couldn't wait I'm not condoning
this okay so don't don't take this as me
condoning it or saying to do it so chat
okay but if you're gonna do it do it
right I swear to because we don't want
him like we don't want all of him we
just want certain parts so that's why we
don't want to upgrade for you that's not
what she said that's not what she said
yeah but she said she doesn't like she
didn't like his lives
that guy in the beginning of the I
listen in the beginning of the show she
said that you you hope that you're gonna
like it'll be something someday or
whatever so I'm like if you're already
emotionally invested you already like
him why don't you just compete and try
to win ask her what does she have that I
don't I'm not I'm not saying I'm not
saying the odds are in your favor ask
the man you know that you come inside
you're gonna I'm just saying if you're
already in that position I would try to
win
and I don't understand like how you can
be like I'm not the one I'm not the one
getting hurt when it's like you're the
side chick and you're emotionally
invested go ahead I think the reason is
insecurity and paranoia of oh he's
cheated on his girl with me so then if I
get with him he's gonna cheat on me if
another girl yeah but you're already
staring at all you're already sharing
everyone's trying to paint us on the men
the road side chick you're not as
emotionally involved like if you're his
actual girlfriend you're in love or or
whatever you're saying you are so as a
side chick you're not you're not doing
that so you said in the beginning that
you're hoping that you'd be promoted to
Maine I mean you didn't use the um
that's how I would describe it you said
it in different words but I remember you
saying that at the beginning I think not
always though like as as a whole lots of
girls get emotionally attached and then
that's when it obviously becomes a
problem you start thinking you know
maybe I could and that's probably when
you start
trying to get him or trying to get him
to make you but in that situation in my
situation I had he wanted me but I
didn't want him so I didn't work so he
wanted he wanted to leave the main chick
for you um and you didn't want him no do
you know what you said you were hoping
I'm not fused not always I think that
like as a as a whole like if you are a
side chick you are hoping for that in
the end but like I didn't I didn't want
that I personally think that side chicks
don't want to become the main chick and
the reason is that no one's really
saying is because they have other men
that they are side chicks too that's
true this is the part that no one's
talking about I don't know a lot about
I'm new to this conversation
I'm learning new stuff I don't want to
get promoted I don't want to get
promoted other options
that I'm working on okay so it's like I
can't work 40 hours a week
I can't I can't work 40 hours a week
because I got all I want to take on
multiple part-time jobs
and if I have a full-time job then I
have to get rid of my part-time jobs
which work out more valuable than a
one-time job I'm making 50k with all of
these so modern women want to be side
chicks absolutely they don't want to be
the man I thought I was feeling you
know I thought I was feeling you was it
you thought I wanted to
plenty of you because the question we
didn't ask you is when you was a side
chick for that dude and you wanted to be
to be the main was you dealing with
somebody else too no you didn't have six
years for six years
there wasn't like someone who was like a
regular like you might end up meeting
someone else on like a night out and
then you get talking for a couple weeks
and then it sort of goes nowhere but
that that person within that six years
is still the same convenience still the
same person you go back but what about
you see when you said you was a side
chick when you was a sidekick to the guy
who was obviously with somebody else did
you have other partners was you with
other people
no not for the majority of the time no
way so when you was a psychic to that
guy you was loyal to your guy
he was loyal to the guy he was a side
chick called basically is that what
you're saying yeah pretty much because
I'm going to him for a reason what if if
I need if he's not fulfilling it what is
the point in going to him
that's what I don't know like three
sidemens
but you said you went on a date and I
slept with someone else after
yeah but it's not like a regular thing I
wouldn't be sleeping with like three
guys at the same time that's horrific
it's multiple attention though yeah
we're playing with we go into the
extreme we'll let you know we're playing
because if if the main guy that you said
that was your guy who used a side chick
for saw the messages that these do that
you ain't serious with right there we go
that's the smile I needed to see
he wouldn't be happy with those he'd be
like who's this who's that what does he
mean by that what does he mean by this
yeah but I didn't have I wasn't that
juggling multiple guys at the same time
but no attention is a currency for women
that men do not have the the benefit of
using men can't use attention as
currency women can use that
as currency in order for us to do that
we have to be in some kind of Scandal
but you can use attention as currency so
as much as you say you're not cheating
you're actually getting attention from
these random dudes is a setup it's like
someone filling out an insurance claim
or filling out a form that's what
they're really doing that's what men are
actually doing when they're when they're
trying to interact with you they're
filling out a form trying to text those
boxes and if you take the right boxes in
the right order the Box opens the big
box opens that's how you get to the big
boxes
it's real [ __ ] that's how you get to the
big boxes by ticking the little box and
Men know that from since we're five
bring her a flower bring her a rose say
something nice open the door for
chivalry we've been taught that for
instance we was a kid so that means you
have been taught something
which is it has to be in response to
that so you know what we want
okay so you
monogamy you wouldn't give up monogamy
no you maybe yeah I'll consider it okay
I'll try it you try it are you jealous
have you guys ever been in a
non-monogamous well I guess she didn't
know it
have you ever been in an openly
non-monogamous relationship guys like
openly yeah like she knows you have a
side check yeah oh yeah was she crazy or
did she just look the other way
no she wasn't
crazy
I mean I wouldn't say would you say it
had to be a relationship yeah it's like
somebody that I was actually seeing yeah
um yeah she wasn't crazy I guess it was
just
I think how that happened is she was
very experimental so she used to bring
girls into the relationship too oh okay
so
it kind of like you know are you
describing polygamy is that what that is
like one-sided one-sided yeah so it's
like you get to do it like she just
looks the other way
but she's faithful to you have you ever
done that
uh
no no no no no
what I've never done that okay I was
just curious because they always
um
girls are like a lot of girls will say
that they've done that or they would try
it I'm just curious if it's ever worked
out for anyone
um like where they actually weren't
jealous
I think most girls who are doing ligamy
most most girls that agree to polygamy
have have other options or seen other
people themselves I believe like she
said earlier if she's in a relationship
she doesn't want to share and all these
things I agree I don't think it would
actually work out I I think that if I
thought about that
I would I would probably get jealous
yeah well I feel like it has worked out
through all throughout all of human
history because only only 40 of that
have reproduced historically
so there's always been two girls for
everyone dude
I was thinking about this the other day
and I was mentioning on the on my
podcast and I was like I think that uh
women a lot of women find it more
comfortable with the they're more
comfortable with the idea that their guy
could be cheating then the idea of them
knowing the person and bringing them in
to the situation they're actually more
comfortable with the guy actually
cheating
no the idea that the guy is cheating
guilty until guilty and do you know what
I mean you know I mean I have a theory
on this gone oh I have a theory on this
yeah so I actually think modern women
like to be cheated on yeah that's my
theory I think they enjoy it because I
swear to God I've had too many girls on
my podcast come on have you ever been
cheated on yes okay when did he cheat
did you leave no when did you leave
after like basically they don't say it
like this but after he stopped and it's
like if you hated and cheated why don't
you leave when he was cheating you leave
when he stopped finding evidence of him
cheating yeah so it's like it's like he
just got smarter hiding it that's what I
said earlier it's like a game for me
once they've conquered you and knocked
you off your pee they don't want you
anymore the second you become what they
want you to become they lose interest
it's just that simple and I've been I've
experienced it I've been there I've seen
it when you try to do everything right
you try you know you try to be
chivalrous you try to be the guy you
know what I'm saying like you try to do
your thing and it's just something in
women's nature that when you give them
too much of what they're asking for they
run it's just it's just it's just
natural but the guy that ignores you
you can't help but
check his story and Oozy waving if he
hollers at you you get an instant
response like it's the idea I don't know
whether it's the the serotonin or the
just the buzz it's the idea that he
might be cheating it's like it just
gives you a rush yeah but the idea that
okay maybe if I what if I know the what
if I know someone you know I mean I'm
I'm kind of it's more of a I'm in
control of the situation as well you
know I mean they'll be like
no no I can't do that no no you know
what you know you ever think about how
women watch The Bachelor and that's one
man dating like a bunch of chicks
bro Flavor Flav had his own show yeah
flavor
flavors I don't know who that is but you
don't know who flavor flavors the old
school go type it a picture of flavor
flavors and he had a he had a show of a
group of women in one house in one house
Flavor of Love Flavor of Love I remember
that yeah it's the same favorite For the
Love of Ray J same thing with Ray J it
happens it's been happening it happened
yeah he sent this one girl home because
she wouldn't do anything sexually that's
what I remember I was like 14 or
whatever and this one girl was my
favorite but yeah then he was like are
you gonna like give me head basically
and then she was like No And then he's
like packing
get out get out yeah okay I'm gonna take
a second to read super chats then we're
gonna do final thoughts and then you can
like shout out any social media you guys
have
um okay am give them what they want give
them what they want these days night fun
for the cost of a meal hookup culture is
just the oldest profession discussed how
do we stay 304 is unreasonable
requirements and stay in the streets
Rebel Rose women can't serve two kings
um bc716 side dude was a great position
for me I got the best I get the best
thing you have to offer and you ain't in
the position to argue with me ever all
pleasure no pain I played my position
for years 90 free-toe pie women really
are too dumb for hypotheticals 90 Frito
pie because of the advances men have
made we made ourselves obsolete XX can
replace men with toys money and Etc yet
remain ungrateful that we made it happen
um sposa um
I'm not reading that one
um okay
uh a.m come on who is surprised the
world is women the world is women who
are six is chasing after tens while
being pursued by fives they want it all
and end up with nothing and have been in
the carousel so long they can't get used
to one partner
um Maurice and tifiak pro tell the
naughty Professor lady to chill the goal
is not always to press the button as men
it is always how many girls we can
conquer
Maurice antifiak
um why buy the cow when I can get the
milk for free the guy and the dreads
needs to get out of his feelings
um King Gail smiak working on your
career and putting your time into your
career and not your children makes you
another dad and not a mother The Savvy
ninja not every man or a woman wants
kids they aren't any less of a man or a
woman if they don't have kids stop this
nonsense marriage with no kids scares
most people if everyone was honest about
it
um Dr bringer 35 is a person that grew
up in a home with Dr parents career
women are selfish and selfish and
useless I was wearing I was raised by a
nanny um 90 Frito pie if I can't go on a
canoe with you then why date you Jeffrey
Murphy she said she would choose your
career over her kid that says every
everything you need to know about her
character 90 Frito pie The Need to Be
Right is strong
um Gus men lie because we talk about our
preferences we get called misogynistic
little dick energy 50 50 relationships
don't work doombringer 30 35 thank you
for the super chats I'm Locas Das sex
women don't take accountability for
their actions and plus today there's way
too much masculinity women want it all
but don't want to work for it um zero
Fallout being stay-at-home moms for the
majority of the time is wrong most were
working class they oh I read this one
already um Let me refresh it and just
make sure also guys like the video
um we should have Let's see we got
998 likes right now we should at least
have 2 000 because we have had over 2
000 people all live so make sure you
like the video a like is free
um okay that's all the super chats so
um you put any social media final
thoughts that you guys want to put so
you can go and then go around all right
so my social media is handles
h-a-n-d-l-e-s-t-d-n for November B
correct spelling
um or you can go to my website tdmb.com
UK and tap in with what I've got going
on man
yeah
I've just got
um install my name is Courtney Moyer
underscore XX
um my Instagram is um Tay underscore
London with three ends
yes yes uh check it out video game
members if you know if your beat
connects you're more likely to get a
woman you want so check it out
yeah side of God so it's um s-i-a-h
underscore t-h-a-g-o-d
um and that's on YouTube I mean that's
on Instagram and also we got um YouTube
which is the dread in it podcast okay so
make sure you go and listen to that and
watch that as well
um yeah that's it yeah
um we got everyone and then Purdy things
and the production team
um yeah my Instagram is scoop God SEO
uup underscore God
and yeah that's it
okay guys a couple announcements before
we end the show um the first is that you
should subscribe to both of our Clips
channels the first is just pearly clips
and the second is Pearl daily make sure
you go subscribe to both
um also guys um sign up for our
membership tiers the first you get to be
a part of our live chat the second you
get our Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs the third you get to
connect with me on social media that
means having access to my inbox and the
fourth is a one-on-one call with me once
a month
um on top of that guys um thank you for
700k um I know I said it in the
beginning of the show but it actually
means the world to me that I get to do
what I love um four nights a week for
you guys and it's just crazy to me it's
literally
um start a YouTube channel because your
whole life could change
um go follow my Instagram just pearly
things one and go follow my tick tocks
justperlythings dot five and just for
early things six
um subscribe to Wife School we're gonna
post the first video after read a
thousand subscribers on its wife's
school with pearl and um thank you for
the super chats tonight guys um like the
video on your way out and we will talk
to you next time